- [Instructor] What we're
gonna do in this video
is think about multiplying, or strategies
for multiplying numbers that are expressed
in terms of hundreds,
or thousands, or tens.
And so we see an example right over here.
We have 800 times 400.
Now like always, I encourage
you to pause this video
and see if you could work
this out on your own.
Now let's work this through together,
and I'm going to work it out in a way
that at least my head likes to tackle it.
Once you get enough practice,
you might even be able
to do these types of
multiplication problems
without even needing to use paper.
So the key realization
here is to say, well look,
this is eight 100s.
So that's the same thing
as eight times 100.
And this over here is four 100s.
So this is four times 100.
And so it's eight times
100, times four times 100.
And if you're multiplying a
bunch of numbers like this,
you can switch the order in which
you're doing the multiplication.
So you can view this as eight times four.
Eight times four, times 100 times 100.
Times 100 times 100.
Times 100.
Now why is this easier?
Well what is eight times four going to be?
Well eight times four, if we
know our times tables, is 32.
And so it's going to be 32 times,
what's 100 times 100 going to be?
Now there's multiple ways
that you can think about this,
and I want you to really think it through,
but we'll soon see that
there's a fairly fast way
of making sure we got it right.
But one way to think about it is,
well let me do it over here.
10 times 100 is equal to 1,000.
And so 100 times 100 is
going to be 10 times that,
or it's going to be equal to 10,000.
So this stuff right over
here is equal to 10,000.
Now you might notice
something interesting here.
I have two zeroes, and
then another two zeroes.
So I have a total of four zeroes.
And then I have four zeroes here.
Because every time you multiply by 10
you're gonna add another zero.
So if you're multiplying by 100
you're gonna add two zeroes.
If you're multiplying by 1,000,
you're gonna add three
zeroes, and you see that here.
So you have 32 times 10,000,
which is going to be what?
Well let's see.
32 times 1,000 would be 32,000.
But this is 32 times 10,000.
So it's going to be 320,000.
Now you might already notice
an interesting pattern here.
32 times one followed by four zeroes
is 32 followed by four zeroes.
This is 32 10,000s, which is 320,000.
Now another was you
could've thought about it
is eight times four gives us our 32.
And then we have two zeroes
there, two zeroes there
for a total of four zeroes,
and we have our four
zeroes right over there.
Now I don't want you
to just memorize that.
It works because this is eight 100s
times four 100s.
Eight times four gives us the 32.
And then the 100 times the 100s,
that's where these four zeroes come from.
Let's do another example.
So let's do, let me delete this.
And let us do, let me get my pen back.
So let's do 30 times 70,
or let's do 30 times 700.
Pause the video and see if
you can figure this out.
So we can do it like we did before,
30 is three times 10.
700, so times 700,
which is seven times 100.
And so if you say three times
seven, is going to be 21
times 10 times 100, is going to be 1,000.
So what's 21 times 1,000?
Well that's going to be 21,000.
Now just like we saw before,
once you get a hang of it,
and I always want you to
understand where it's coming from,
three times seven is the 21,
and then you're gonna multiply
that times 10 and then 100.
So you have one, two, three zeroes.
One, two, three zeroes.
Let's do one more of these.
So let's say we wanted to
multiply 2,000 times 8,000.
Pause the video and see if you
can figure out what this is.
Maybe in your head.
Try to do this one in your head.
Or on paper, don't feel bad
if you need to use paper.
That's always prudent.
Well you might get the hang of it now.
You might be able to
do this quite quickly.
You might be able to say
hey, two times eight,
well that's going to be equal to 16.
And then I have
three plus three zeroes,
so that's gonna be six zeroes.
One, two, three, four, five, six,
which gives me 16 million.
You would absolutely be correct.
Now I want to reinforce what you're doing
when you're just counting
zeroes like that.
What you're doing, you're just saying hey,
this is the same thing as two times 1,000,
times eight times 1,000.
Eight times 1,000.
And then you're just changing
the order of multiplication.
You're saying hey, let me
multiply the two and the eight.
You multiply the two times
the eight, and you get 16.
And then you multiply the
times 1,000 times 1,000.
So times 1,000 times 1,000.
And 1,000 1,000s, that's one million.
This is one million right over here.
And notice you see it there too.
1,000 times 1,000, you have
three zeroes, three zeroes,
you get six zeroes.
1,000 1,000s is a million.
16 times a million is 16 million.
So hopefully that helps and makes you
a little more comfortable
multiplying these numbers
that are multiples of ten, hundred,
thousands, even millions.